cleansing is really important when you
start off with skin care everyone is
really excited about actives exfoliants
retinoids vitamin C people kind of
assume cleansing isn't that important
because cleanser is only on your skin
for a little bit you wash it off it
doesn't really matter what you use that
is completely wrong cleansing is the
step of your routine where your skin is
at its most vulnerable the barrier gets
Disturbed and can stay Disturbed for
hours a cleansing routine that isn't
right for your skin can lead to
breakouts rough and Flaky dehydrated
skin irritation I notice a huge
difference in my skin since I found the
right cleansing routine and I hope this
video helps you too hi I'm Michelle of
lab muffin Beauty science and I am a big
cleanser Advocate today I'm going to do
a deep dive into the different types of
cleansing products and how they fit into
a routine this video is sponsored by
star Korean who stock the products I'll
be mentioning today the most basic
Central kind of cleanser is the wash off
cleanser it might be the first skincare
product you ever used want to look for
in a cleanser there are a lot of myths
around what to look for in a cleanser a
lot of them are based on outdated
information or brand marketing I talk
more about picking and using cleansers
in my book the lab muffin guide to basic
skincare but here are some of the main
points any form of a cleanser can be
gentle including bars and foaming
cleansers there are lots of ways to make
cleanses foam more without getting
harsher there are harsh and gentle
cleanses with and without foam it
depends on the specific cleanser
moisturizing and soothing ingredients
are a good sign in general cleanses with
more different surfactants those are
cleansing ingredients and a pH closer to
skin four to six are gentler there are
exceptions to these general principles
formulation techniques and ingredients
are always improving Check reviews from
people with similar skin to you before
you buy and if you can try a sample on
your own skin how do you use a cleanser
there are lots of different types of
rinse off cleansers the simplest sort of
cleanser is probably a foaming cleanser
to use these you squeeze out a small
amount lather it in your hands with some
water rub it over your face and then
rinse with slightly warm water then you
part the water off your face gently with
a towel with non-foaming cleansers you
do the same but without the lathering
step there are a few cleanses that have
special instructions so always check the
label how much cleanser should you use
there aren't really any strict rules on
this in general you just need enough to
spread around your face usually around
an almond sized amount does your face
need to be wet before you apply the
cleanser again there isn't really a
right and a wrong answer it's usually
easier to use cleansers on wet skin
because the water already on your face
adds to it and there's just more liquid
to spread around some cleansers can also
stick to dry skin and be hard to rinse
off but if you're removing makeup or
sunscreen then you probably have to
massage cleanser into your face for
longer so it might be less messy to
apply to dry skin and maybe skip the
lathering step there are also other
products you can use for removing makeup
we'll talk more about that later how
long should you massage for again there
aren't strict rules you just need to rub
the cleanser on your skin for long
enough that the dirt and the oils get
lifted by the cleansing surfactants
there's no benefit to letting a soak on
your skin for longer and you might risk
more irritation you're giving any
irritating ingredients a longer time to
burrow into your skin while it's
vulnerable and cause prolonged
irritation if a cleanser has actives the
instructions might say to leave it on
for longer the cleanse has been designed
and tested to be used that way and yes
active ingredients can work in wash off
cleansers it's the same for moisturizing
ingredients cleansers can be formulated
so that some ingredients can stay stuck
to skin even through rinsing the abib
acne foam cleanser is a gentle cleanse
I've been really enjoying it forms a
nice foam and it doesn't strip my skin
which is great because so many acne
cleansers are harsh it has salicylic
acid in it to help with acne it's been
found to work well in cleansers and you
can see some of those gentle cleanser
formulation features here there's a mix
of surfactants and a bunch of soothing
and moisturizing ingredients including
heart leaf and centella extracts it's
fragrance free apart from those plants
tracks some cleanses come in cell
foaming pumps that mix air into the
cleanser so that it makes the lather for
you they are super convenient these
cleansers are formulated to be very
runny so that they work with the pump
correctly but that doesn't mean it's
less concentrated something I didn't
realize until I started learning about
formulations is that for almost every
product the texture gets adjusted with
special thickening ingredients so how
thick a product is doesn't tell you
anything about how watered down it is in
fact for most cleansing surfactants the
texture is pretty thin when it's at 100
then it gets thicker when you add more
water and then it thins down again so
it's a myth that cell foaming cleanses
are bad value because they're watered
down and use them up faster it really
depends on the product and the pump with
this Etude sunjang whip cleanser one
pump is 0.8 grams and that is enough to
clean my whole face this is pretty
similar to the amounts of other
cleansers I use this is really gentle
again you can see how it has a lot of
moisturizing and soothing ingredients
like Pantheon and metacast aside those
are in the whole sunjang range there's
two surfactants which you might think
would be less gentle than more
surfactants but both of these are very
gentle on their own and often used in
baby products they even have a bit of a
moisturizing effect it's also fragrance
free so one cleanser is all you need for
a very basic cleansing routine but you
can also add steps before and after if
you wear makeup or a very resilient
sunscreen you might want to use other
products to get them off first regular
cleansers can remove these depending on
the cleanser and what you're removing
but a lot of people prefer to double
cleanse which is very popular in a lot
of Asian style skincare routines
basically this is where you wash your
face twice usually with two different
cleansers most commonly you start with
an oil-based cleanser like a cleansing
balm or cleansing oil then follow that
with a regular foaming cleanser all base
cleansers are really good at shifting
water resistant makeup and sunscreens
with minimal effort and they are really
relaxing to use they also contain
surfactants so when you rest with water
the oil lifts off your skin and washes
away some of these rinse off really
cleanly others leave an oily film that
is sometimes a feature of the product
the oils are meant to be beneficial but
some people find that they break out if
they don't use another cleanser
afterwards in terms of what to look for
it is really about preference what
texture packaging fragrance you want
whether you want it to rinse off cleanly
or leave a film what active ingredients
you like to use a cleansing oil you
massage about an almond sized Mount onto
dry skin I'm using the skim 104
Madagascar centella light cleansing oil
one of my favorite cleansing oils it's
very lightweight it has a lot of
soothing ingredients and it comes in a
handy pump it doesn't leave much residue
afterwards like with other cleansers
cleansing oils don't really cleanse
better if you leave them sitting on your
skin for ages your skin is usually clean
after less than 30 seconds of rubbing
but if you massage them gently for a
little bit longer up to five minutes you
can get blackheads to pop out the
massaging and the oil loosens them it's
really satisfying when you feel these
grits there are lots of ways of
encouraging more grits to come out like
letting the oil soak into your pores
before you massage using a clay mask
I'll link a tutorial in the description
once you're done with that you rinse
with water the water will look milky
that is the tiny drops of oil coming off
into the water then you can either
follow up with a second cleanser or pat
dry and go on with the rest of your
skincare routine cleansing balms are
used in pretty much the same way except
they're more solid you scoop out a
little and massage it gently into dry
skin in colder places you might want to
melt it a bit in your hands first I
personally prefer cleansing bars because
they're a bit less messy to get onto my
face than an oil this is the Hamish all
clean balm one of my favorite cleansing
balms your shifts make up really easily
it rinses off cleanly it comes in a
convenient flip top tub and it's
affordable I'd recommend this to anyone
unless you're allergic to something in
it this is their New Mandarin version
which is pretty much the same as the
original except for the scent it's a
slightly floral Citrus essential oil
smell once you're done massage you rinse
it off if you wear heavy eyeliner or
lipstick you might want to remove them
with a separate product if you want just
the one product you can use a cleansing
oil or balm a lot of them are designed
to remove eye and lip makeup as well but
I prefer using a cotton pad with a too
vase makeup remover this is the ilium
fresh moisture lip and eye remover you
can see there are two layers of liquid
inside the top layer is oil based the
bottom is water-based so that means it
can dissolve both oily and watery makeup
you shake it up put a bit on your cotton
pad and wipe it over your eyes and lips
for really stubborn makeup you can hold
the wet pad over your makeup to let it
soak in and soften I find this faster to
use than an oil base cleanser because
the pad grabs onto makeup and gets into
the skin folds more easily than just my
fingers plus it's really easy to see
whether you have makeup left on your
skin some cleansing oils and balms can
also leave your eyes blurry for a bit
which generally isn't harmful just a bit
annoying most of these removers use a
mix of lightweight oil so it doesn't
leave a noticeable residue though you
should check the reviews this ilium one
is really lightweight I use it at the
very start of my cleansing routine
before other cleanses there are lots of
rinse off treatments that you can use
after cleansing I think of these as part
of my cleansing routine to prepare my
skin before all the leave-on steps one
of my favorite underrated product
categories is peeling gels also called
gamages These are super gentle but very
thorough physical exfoliants as you rub
them into your skin they Bunch up into
soft fibers it's like a super gentle
scrub you massage about an arm is worth
gently into your skin you'll feel those
fibers bunching up know those rolls are
not dead skin removing that much dead
skin would hurt a lot this is the beauty
of chosen apricot Blossom peeling gel
the main scrubbing ingredient is
cellulose it also has exfoliating
enzymes in it to add to that effect this
can be used on wet or dry skin but some
peeling gels will form a weird film on
wet skin that's hard to remove make sure
you check the instructions after a
minute or two of massaging you rinse it
off I use it about twice a week but it
depends on your skin tolerance I talk
more about how to build up an
exfoliation routine in this guide there
are lots of different rinse off masks
that you can use at this stage some of
these can be annoying because they have
to be cleansed off so you end up
cleansing they're masking and then
cleansing again a lot of clay masks are
like this but there are also Clay
cleansers like this one from jacobo that
do it all in the one step it has clay
particles that soak up oil and exfoliate
gently as you cleanse if you have oily
skin the clay can help to soak up oil
and keep your skin from getting shiny
for longer so let's talk about what a
cleansing routine might look like the
simplest cleansing routine might simply
look like this use a cleanser like one
of these then apply your leave-on
products like Essences serums and
moisturizer if you wear makeup or
sunscreen you might want to double
cleanse and then maybe have a separate
eye or lip makeup remover you can also
use other rinse off treatments after
cleansing like a peeling gel that's a
really quick rundown of how to cleanse
there's a lot about cleansing I didn't
get to in this video so check out my
other videos on cleansing and the lab
basic skincare for more on this links to
all the products in the description and
happy getting stuff off your face